rated M for Mature
Game of Thrones fans playing the
telltale Game will
flesh out that all immersive experience
what Westeros is you get to be a part of
and we'll get a little bit more of the
world you get to choose what happens you
can get involved and create your own
storyline you get to go on a series of
adventures that are determined by you
the player so you can create your own
storyline involving Daenerys and her
dragons my character Margaery Tyrell is
one of the principal characters that the
gamer meets Meera Forrester is I'm a
handmaiden of Margaery Tyrell it's great
the gamer gets to interact directly with
the wanna be queen of Westeros allies
and enemies can be made with every move
yet they say it is men who are powerful
my character Ramsay basically involves
in the same way as you generally causing
havoc around Westeros Roderick we've had
a lovely time together
say it say it's been lovely
I think it's just magical that you as
the player can determine your own fate
within the realms of Game of Thrones the
show that we know if fleshes out
Westeros more which is is fun for fans
of the show and the game you too will
join Croft in his men get them into the
city help them liberate marine and I
will see that you are awarded there's
like repercussions to every decision
that you make so I think it's a really
interesting way of approaching a game
you can get involved and create the way
that you would do it so as opposed to
just shouting at the television you can
you can take action and do it yourself
this is wonderful ability of giving a
Game of Thrones fan the experience of
meeting these different characters going
to these different places and really
expanding their enjoyment and richness
of the Game of Thrones experience they
get to be a part of the show which if
you if you love a show that much but
that's kind of a wonderful experience